134 logements sociaux vieillissant
lapointe allongées à deux entrées de
ville les clayes-sous-bois et villepreux
datant des années 1970 le quartier va
connaître une réhabilitation complète on
a décidé de lancer avec le groupe
polylogis et le bailleur logirep un
grand projet de réhabilitation à la fois
de l'extérieur mais aussi de l'intérieur
pour que les pièces d'eau notamment et
l'intérieur des logements soit
réhabilité et que les habitants les
locataires puissent avoir des conditions
de vie plus acceptable initialement
intégré dans le projet central park
porté par la municipalité précédente le
quartier de la pointe à l'enjeu va se
voir dotée de nouveaux logements 20
logements locatifs sociaux et 34 bourrée
elle solidaire il ya un objectif aussi
de pouvoir valoriser l'activité
commerciale nous avons sept commerces
d'ailleurs je précise que l'activité ne
sera aucunement interrompue pendant les
travaux de réhabilitation donc c'est de
pouvoir aussi accompagner nos acteurs
économiques et pérenniser leur
implantation sur ce quartier une surface
de 100 mètres carrés pourrait prendre la
place des actuels locaux associatifs les
travaux devraient débuter fin 2022 le
projet devrait se terminer à l'horizon